may the 4th be with you it is Star Wars
day and as promised on my Facebook and
Twitter if you've been keeping up with
me I'm going to be reviewing every
single Star Wars theatrical film once a
month until episode 7 this December and
we are starting off with the best one
Episode one The Phantom Menace I'm
kidding let's talk about it now I'm well
aware there are plenty of fans of the
prequels out there there's lots of
people who enjoy these movies and
they've had to endure people hating on
them and trashing them for many many
years and well there are fans of the
prequels out there I think the majority
of us can agree they were very
disappointing movies and I'm going to do
my best to do a level-headed review of
The Phantom Menace because we're many
years away from the release now we've
all had time to process it we've all had
time to think about it and in my notes I
actually wrote don't hate on it
unnecessarily just because you feel like
it I'm going to do my best so it's
almost impossible for me to review this
movie without giving a humongous thank
you and shout out to red letter media
because their review for the Phantom
Menace is quite possibly my favorite
movie review of all time they said
everything it's to be said plus a whole
bunch of things no one else ever thought
of but as a massive star wars fan I have
a lot of things to say this movie came
out at a perfect time for me I was 11
when the Phantom Menace came out all of
you people are always wondering how old
I am
I'm 27 I was honestly the perfect age
for this movie 11 I was right there at
the cusp of getting into my teenage
years but still a boy and still sitting
in this movie theater as the movie began
the dialogue started something just felt
off this is getting out of hand
now they're all two of them there are
things I'm very thankful for Phantom
Menace for like for instance episode 1
podracer on the Nintendo 64 or episode 1
battle for Naboo I had so much fun with
these games and I still enjoy playing
them every once in a while I was
collecting the Star Wars toys at the
time like Darth Maul and obi-wan Kenobi
and mace windu and c-3po and I had all
kinds of stuff I mean young Jedi cards I
was so into it my friends and I even
held pretend radio shows we recorded our
voices onto cassette tape and tried to
pretend to be Star Wars characters it
was a maze
hi my name is Christopher Stockman on
The Late Late Late Early Show at seven
o'clock in the morning on Channel five
hey our first guest name is Luke
Skywalker
how you doing Logan good
well that's good do you have an asthma
attack and I also found an old TV Guide
from 1999 with an interview with Liam
Neeson right before the Phantom Menace
came out and the opening paragraph of
said interview revealed quite a bit Liam
Neeson was so eager to be in the Phantom
Menace he accepted the role of the stern
Jedi Knight qui-gon jinn without reading
one word of George Lucas's script Oh
in fact this movie had such an impact on
the pop culture before was released as
well as afterwards that I came up with a
term to describe it and I call it
phantom menacing any film can be Phantom
Menace you can be so excited for this
movie you feel like your entire life's
happiness is riding on the success of
this movie you get so pumped out of your
mind that you might actually cry when
you get the chance to see it then you
see it and you leave the theater and you
become in denial about how bad it
actually was and you stay in denial for
many years until you eventually reveal
to yourself you know what that wasn't
that good and I'm not going to be a
hypocrite about this I did this myself
in 2008 with a little film called
Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull that was my exact
experience with that movie as a fan at
that age I was too young to really
notice how stupid the special edition
enhancements were but I saw them in
theaters I was so excited for it I love
seeing the originals I was collecting
the toys that were released at that time
I had Star Wars pogs who else remembers
pogs and as we're sitting in the theater
we begin to realize we're watching a
movie about political squabbling trade
negotiations and peace treaty signings
and backhanded politics and Senate
meetings and when you actually read
about how this movie was filmed and that
they only built sets for the backgrounds
high enough to keep the actors eye line
in frame and then they had to spend all
this extra money because Liam Neeson is
six foot four to build higher sets when
you think about that that's kind of
funny but then you realize wait a second
they only built a couple walls behind
these actors and didn't even give them
an environment or a room to really stand
in that often they were basically just
walking around a green
or a blue screen room that doesn't help
your actor at all and when you
constantly tell your actor to go faster
and more intense and that's all you say
you're going to have performances that
all feel the same and when you watch The
Phantom Menace I challenge you to find a
performance excluding Jar Jar
that's not my people need help I want
you to sign the peace treaty nothing can
get through our shields
my name is qui-gon jinn my name is
obi-wan Kenobi my name is Anakin
Skywalker are you an angel every
performance in this movie is on the same
level of emotion because there is no
real actor director relationship going
on here you can tell that even in more
intense scenes where the fish is chasing
after their boat underwater that
everyone just feels like they're going
through a drive in the country but as
you watch the movie I challenge you to
figure out who the main character of
this movie is you can't it's not quite
gone it's not obi-wan Kenobi and it's
not Anakin who's the main character of
this movie Liam Neeson gets top billing
so maybe qui-gon is in a way it almost
seems like qui gonn is the main
character of the movie but why would you
do that who the hell is qui-gon he's an
older Stern Jedi who is really Stern and
what exactly is his character actually
and then of course there's Jar Jar
now look every single thing that could
have been said about this thing has been
said already so I'm just gonna say one
thing when he's first introduced and
qui-gon jinn says the ability to speak
does not make you intelligent not good
out of here
I wish Jar Jar had listened but of
course she had to go no no Mesa stay me
so your life dad this scuba there will
be for me Ruby Toby Scooby dooby naari
watching this movie recently on my 1080p
television I began to realize you know
what this movie is starting to look very
dated
the CGI just doesn't hold up as well
anymore because there's an over-reliance
on it yes there is more attempts at
practical imagery in the Phantom Menace
than in the last two prequels but the
over-reliance on cgi and the constant
attempts of just throwing so many
computer-generated images into one shot
without any real composure or structure
makes the entire film look very dated
the original trilogy still remains
timeless save for a few shots we can
really tell that just doesn't look that
great
that's because they use real models that
were tangible things in existence that
are always going to be real things that
were in existence filmed by an actual
camera so it's always going to look good
the over reliance on the digital imagery
and the prequels are now starting to
make them look dated and eventually
they're going to look even more dated
and that is just one of the biggest
technical flaws in this movie even for
its time in 1999 the lifeless doll
battle droids that can be cut in half in
an instant provided absolutely no
tension the stormtroopers couldn't hit
anything in the original films but at
least they were people and you felt some
tension there
you really did feel suspense when the
Jedi walk out and go assume services
those are those and everything's just
done that's cool they're badasses
they're in their prime we know we
understand that excuse has been made for
many years but that doesn't mean the
movies going to have any more suspense
or tension that it could have in that
action because everything looks so well
choreographed and there's not even a
lick of fear on their faces they don't
look concerned at all
so the overall plot of this movie is
that the Trade Federation want to invade
and Palpatine once Queen Amidala to
sign a peace treaty somehow making all
of this work out for him in a way and he
wants her to move for a vote of no
confidence on Chancellor valorum so that
he can then replace him in power and do
his evil stuff in the background and yes
there's a large portion of this movie
dedicated to this in the original
trilogy the emperor's plan was to turn
father against son use Vader to entice
Luke to join the dark side this is an
emotional internal battle and the
Emperor did all of that behind the
scenes in such clever ways in this film
his evil scheme is he really wants Queen
Amidala to sign a paper
Wu now eventually the best part of this
movie is introduced and that is Darth
Maul
now why is Darth Maul so awesome why
does everyone like Darth Maul why is
everyone sad that Darth Maul died at the
end of this movie because he was one of
the best characters why did so many
expanded universe novels and even a
television show decide to resurrect him
because he doesn't have any lines he
says like three things at last we will
reveal ourselves to the Jedi at last we
will have revenge my traces were correct
I will find him quickly master and there
you go Darth Maul he looks awesome he
sounds cool he's a badass he does his
own stunts he's got an awesome
lightsaber and he can kick Jedi's asses
and he's not even a Sith master yet but
he doesn't have hardly any lines to say
so he barely has to say anything written
by George Lucas that's a major plus for
a character in this movie now after this
amazing teaser poster we were all really
pumped to see what Anakin Skywalker was
going to be like and George Lucas
apparently saw jingle all the way and
said yeah that kid that's who we need I
just don't understand how certain takes
for this movie we're like yeah that's a
good one I mean weren't people behind
the scenes like watching going like I
don't know about that man you'll never
reach the outskirts of time sandstorms
are
very dangerous no there really wasn't
anyone because if you watch the
documentary of this movie which is
incredibly revealing it actually shows
George Lucas after the first rough-cut
screening with the producers and various
people and they all look like they're
ready to jump off a cliff this little is
joined it seems like a lot of short
scenes it's bold in terms of jerking
people around but I may have gone too
far in a few places and just when you
thought that the Star Wars saga couldn't
get any more confusing George Lucas
decided to introduce midi-chlorians into
the mix that's right apparently everyone
just has little microscopic organisms
floating around the inside of their
bodies and whoever listens to them
correctly can understand the force it's
not a mystical thing that binds us
together with everyone in the galaxy
it's just these little organisms that
live inside our body so I came to the
Padre sequence and I watched it through
adult eyes now these are eyes that
analyze movies I like to analyze the way
shots are cut together the way sound is
looped through a scene I like to look at
the lighting I like to look at the way
the camera moves and as I watch this
scene I became aware of something that
I've never noticed before in fact I've
never heard anyone mentioned ever nearly
every single shot in the podrace is from
the right hand perspective of the pods
and I would say about 80% of the shots
are panning from left to right pan from
left to right left to right left to
right left to right left to right left
to right left to right if you think I'm
showing the same shot over and over
again I'm not these are all different
shots for some reason Lucas never
thought to put the camera on the other
side of the pods so you don't get a
well-rounded view of this race and it
becomes very stale because you're
constantly seeing the same movement
happen left to right left to right over
and over again I can't believe I never
noticed this I mean yeah there are shots
like from straight on or from straight
behind our first person shot but I think
there are maybe one or two shots that
are actually on the left hand side it's
nuts I never noticed this before the
entire scene feels stale to me now and
I'm sorry if I ruined it for anybody so
once these characters finally get to
Khorasan and go to the Jedi Council and
we get to see Yoda and mace windu and
all these people and
why God is trying to convince them that
Anakin's got something special about him
and they need to train him the inclusion
of a humorless witless dry as boring
Yoda was an awful idea
Anakin is the one who will eventually
bring balance to the force this is the
prophecy and here's the boy yet every
single person on this council is like
he's too old we don't like him go away
just know he's not gonna be trained shut
up the Jedi is in this movie are dicks
I'm serious when you actually watch this
movie and you hear about them constantly
saying the syph menace and the mystery
of the Sith and qui-gon you should go
out and do something about that and they
just sit around in a room and go yeah
that's all they do in the movie they
don't actually do anything finally an
attack of the clones they got like a
thousand Jedi just in a room just
fighting where were they when Darth
Maul was cutting people in half now
throughout this entire Khorasan sequence
it is some of them also boring
adventure cereal fun awesome science
fiction filmmaking I've ever seen in my
life throughout this entire sequence and
I call it a sequence even though it's
like a half an hour's worth of various
scenes I call it a sequence because it
just feels like this giant thing that
won't go away everyone is just sitting
and talking walking and talking one
person sits while another person walks
and talks everyone just keeps sitting
around in rooms and talking there's a
basic rule of screenwriting guys and
what that is is if you have to have a
talking scene that doesn't do that much
of an intense nature and you really just
need this scene where people are talking
to maybe advance a few plot points long
try to put it in a location or have
something going on that's interesting
for instance in JJ Abrams original Star
Trek film when bones and Kirk have to
have some expository dialogue they
decided to have a scene in which Kirk's
hands blow up from this injection that
bones gave him and they have to run
around trying to heal Kirk but they're
also giving the dialogue that's needed
at that time now that makes for a
humorous scene a fun and exciting scene
while also giving you the necessary
dialogue that's how you do a talking
scene that doesn't have that much to do
with the plot not just people sitting
around going yes that's a good idea
oh I'm over
vote of no confidence in Chancellor
valorum who gives a seriously who
cares this move is made for kids you
really think they're gonna sit down and
watch that a Senate meeting now once we
finally get to the finale this movie
most of us are just excited to see
something happening besides a trade
dispute Darth Maul qui-gon jinn and
obi-wan are having a pretty cool
lightsaber battle I actually really like
this lightsaber battle I will not lie
it's a lot of fun John Williams duel the
faith song is brilliant I actually had
the privilege of hearing him perform it
live in concert that was awesome I
remember hearing it before seeing the
movie I was so excited I was listening
to it going oh my gosh this is gonna be
the best movie of all time or goodness
gracious movies gonna be so amazing ah
yes but I do really like this lightsaber
fight even though nothing of much
internal conflict is going on it's
really just two Jedi's and a guy and
they're cool and they're in a cool room
and Scott the FEC's and it's cool and
Obi one should have totally used his
speed run to go through the red blaster
door area but of course he didn't
because screenplay by George Lucas
so Anakin's flying around in a boost
Starfighter and he eventually blows up
the ship and everything but something
about that scene always bothered me
he's got a child size helmet in the
cockpit now can you imagine how much
better of a scene it would have been if
he had to wear an adult size helmet and
it didn't fit and he had to try to see
out of it it would have been fun it
would have made the scene more
entertaining if he actually had to try
to fit into an adult helmet but no he
has the convenient child size helmet
just there for some reason
it's these various ideas that could have
been in so many scenes to make them
better that Lucas never thinks of so the
best character in the whole movie gets
cut in half after qui-gon jinn dies and
says you have to train the boy please
it's my dying wish please train the boy
he will bring balance so Obi Wan is then
forced to train Anakin even though he
doesn't want to
and apparently Yoda is fine with it all
of a sudden he's like agree with you the
council does but you just like 20
minutes ago said no like what changed
it's just kind of stupid that obi-wan is
forced to train Anakin and all honesty
qui-gon jinn should have even been in
this movie it should just bend obi-wan
Kenobi he finds Anakin because they're
supposed to be friends nothing in the
Phantom Menace is hey obi-wan and
it's just like hey you're a kid and I'm
on a ship complaining about the weather
and blah blah blah and that's it
the guy's completely honest talk here
The Phantom Menace is not Battlefield
Earth bad it's not troll too bad it's
just a vastly disappointing movie and
when I say that I mean that it really
really is a disappointing movie if you
like it that's fine but I just don't
understand that but that's me if you
like it that's cool man you're allowed
you're allowed to like the Phantom
Menace
I just don't personally I'm going to
give Star Wars Episode one The Phantom
Menace a c-minus now after that review
you may have been thinking wow he's
going to give it an F or something but
I'm being realistic you can sit down and
watch this movie and it has some
entertaining scenes is a very below
average movie and that is not good
because every other Star Wars film
previous was as close to perfect as I
wanted it to be so the fact that this
movie is that bad even is really awful
so guys as promised once a month I'm
going to be reviewing every theatrical
Star Wars film stay tuned next month for
Attack of the Clones I'm really excited
for this guy's and thank you so much
again as always for watching happy may
the fourth day and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes